[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 175 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel,
and I'm here today
with my colleague, Jon Foust.
Jon, how are you doing?
JON FOUST: I'm doing great.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
Glad to hear it.
I hope it's warmer in
New York than it is here
in San Francisco.
JON FOUST: I don't think so.
It's like 50.
It's like 50 degrees right now.
MARK MANDEL: OK, that's
not particularly warm.
So this week, we're
talking to Andrew Davidson
from MongoDB, talking
all about the platform
and how people can use it
on top of Google Cloud.
JON FOUST: Very awesome.
Got to meet him on the showcase
floor a little bit earlier, so
really excited to
talk to this guy.
MARK MANDEL: But before
we talk to Andrew,
we have our usual
question of the week,
where you're going to ask me,
how can I access the Google
Cloud shell from any terminal?
It's like magic.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it
sounds very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But before we do that, we
have our usual cool things
of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jon, why don't you go first?
I know you have a good one.
JON FOUST: Sure.
We are announcing the
Indie Games Accelerator,
which is a program that
is accepting the top indie
developers and flying them out
to our Google Singapore office,
where they will
attend a program that
helps them manifest
their actual game
and get ready for Google Play.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Very nice.
As we both know,
we both love games.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
JON FOUST: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
I want to highlight a project
that was started and worked
on by one of our team
members, Seth Vargo.
It is a project called Berglas.
I'm going to assume I'm
pronouncing that correctly.
It is an open source project
that is a command line tool
and library for storing
and retrieving secrets
on Google Cloud.
So basically, if you
just want a really nice
wrapped up tool for taking
things like passwords, things
that are secret credentials,
things like that,
encrypting them with KMS,
storing them, retrieving
them, that kind of stuff,
Berglas is for you.
You should check it out.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
JON FOUST: Moving on, we are
talking about the American
Cancer Association using Google
Cloud to empower their cancer
research.
The study accepts a little bit
more than 184 men and women
and looks into their
height, weight,
demographic characteristics,
personal family history.
And they use this data
to actually help analyze
breast cancer tissue,
samples, and other things
that they are trying to fight.
Because cancer is one
of the leading causes
of death in America.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome work.
So our good friends,
NVIDIA, we've
had a recent episode
talking about their T4s
back in February, Episode 168.
But the great news is, is the
T4 is now generally available.
So if you have particular
needs around high performance
computing, machine
learning, training,
and inference, data analytics,
graphics, et cetera,
you can now take advantage
of general availability
of the NVIDIA T4 GPU.
JON FOUST: And I think it's
generally available in roughly
around eight regions right now.
MARK MANDEL: That seems
about right, yeah.
JON FOUST: And to
wrap things up,
this is a really cool story.
There's a 17-year-old
scientist who's
interning at NASA named Lisa
Goldberg, who's actually
using Google Earth
Engine to analyze forest
change at a global scale.
So she's tracking
climate change,
which is really awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
Inspirational.
JON FOUST: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, why don't we go chat
with our buddy, Andrew?
And he can tell us all
the things about MongoDB.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Welcome.
We are joined today by Andrew
Davidson from Mongo, DB.
Hey, Andrew.
How's it going?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Doing
real well, thank you.
Good to be here on the floor
of the Google Next Conference
Expo.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Awesome.
You want to tell us a
little bit about yourself?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sure, yes.
I'm Andrew Davidson.
I'm the Director of Cloud
Products for MongoDB.
We're a company with a global
headquarters in New York City,
but we're all over the world.
And I live in New York,
been there about six years
now with MongoDB.
But I'm from the
Bay Area originally,
so I'm really happy to be
getting my fill of burritos
while I'm in town.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So that's a lengthy
title you have there--
Director of Cloud Services.
What does that mean?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yeah,
I mean, I primarily
focus on MongoDB Atlas, which
is our database as a service
from a product
perspective, so ensuring
that what we're building
is a great experience
for our customers, giving them
a global database as a service
on GCP for MongoDB.
JON FOUST: As a former
New Yorker, welcome.
Well, actually, what is MongoDB?
Because a lot of us
haven't actually touched
MongoDB in a while, some of us.
So yeah, feel free to
tell us what that is.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sounds good.
Yeah, we talk to folks who
range the whole spectrum of,
I used MongoDB n years ago,
and my experience of that
was probably something that
was this thing I could download
and I found online or on some
tutorial, like, back in 2014,
to folks who are really just--
MARK MANDEL: That's kind of
accurate, actually, but yeah.
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
There's those folks,
and then there's folks building
mission critical applications
on MongoDB today, who know
it kind of inside and out.
And then there's folks
who haven't used it all,
and they've just been
using relational databases,
table-based database
their whole life.
So MongoDB is a
document database.
And basically, the
reason why it took off,
the reason why it's just been so
popular, really the core reason
is it just stores natively
the JSON data model, which
is what developers love.
They take their objects
right in their code,
and they get to write them
directly to the database.
They don't need that object
relational map anymore.
They don't have that
impedance mismatch.
And then with that
JSON data, which
is the new standard across
the board, with MongoDB,
they can index into
any of the fields,
into any of the
arrays, sub documents.
So they don't give up any
of the rich queryability
that they need to build
modern applications.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Is that what you find, generally
speaking, why you see customers
coming to NoSQL in general?
Is it that added flexibility?
Is that kind of
what's going on there?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: That's
a great question.
We don't tend to
use the term NoSQL,
and I'll tell you
why in a minute.
In my view, NoSQL is kind of--
a lot of people, when they
hear that, I think they think
of a specific kind of
database called key-value.
And key-value is kind of a
subset of what MongoDB can do.
Because it's a simple naive
document where you just index
on one field and look up on it.
That's essentially key-value.
But the ability to
also be able to index
on any compound set
of fields, et cetera,
makes it a much
more rich structure.
So document kind of
becomes the superset
of key-value and something
more like our traditional
table-based databases.
The reason that's
important is what
drove the adoption of
these NoSQL databases
over the last 10 years--
MARK MANDEL: Although
you don't use that term.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Well, when
I say these, I'm talking--
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
you mean broadly.
Broadly, yeah, OK.
Go.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: What drove
the adoption was basically
scalability and availability
requirements forcing
us to break away from
traditional, monolithic,
table-based databases.
So a lot of us kind of
mentally, when we hear NoSQL,
we jump into the idea of super
scalable key-value stores.
But all of a sudden,
with key-value stores,
you give up all
the queryability,
so you end up doing a ton of
ETL into relational system,
just to kind of maintain
your reporting, et cetera.
MongoDB is this
perfect sweet spot.
You've got that JSON data
model we talked about.
You've got the scalability
that comes from a distributed
system, comes from
horizontal scale-out
with MongoDB sharding.
You've got the high availability
that comes from the distributed
system, replication built in,
fault tolerance, auto failover.
You've got the ability
to move the data
and have it be where it needs
to be, closest to users.
So you've got data
locality latency concerns.
All of that, you can only do
with the distributed systems.
You need a modern
database for that.
And then you've got
the ubiquity of being
able to run it anywhere, ranging
from the developer laptop,
to corporate data
center, to Google Cloud
on MongoDB Atlas as a service.
So I think we're uniquely
positioned in the market
to have all those things.
And that's what's just driving
modern application developers
for general purpose workloads.
JON FOUST: So you
just mentioned Atlas.
And I know that we have just
announced our partnership
with MongoDB.
You care to talk a little
bit more about Atlas
for our listeners?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sure.
So MongoDB Atlas is
a global database
as a service for MongoDB.
It's elastic, meaning you can
scale at any time, vertically
or horizontally
with no downtime.
It's very much a
declarative model.
So what we've kind of
seen is this proliferation
of application developers
are moving to a model
where they're
breaking everything
up into microservices.
And each microservice
in the new paradigm
will typically have its
own database behind it.
And what that means
is there's kind
of a proliferation of
large numbers of databases,
more than ever before.
You don't just kind of have
that one large monolith database
someone's maintaining
in the middle anymore.
Instead, there's dozens
of them around the shop,
doing all kinds
of little services
to massive back ends for
the core of the application.
What that means is you need to
be able to abstract away all
of the overhead
concern, frankly,
plumbing that goes into
managing not just databases,
but everything underneath
them-- the infrastructure,
the cloud instances,
the operating system,
the networking security
configurations,
and all of the rest--
and instead have
it be encapsulated
in just declarative, API
call ready, descriptive.
I get a cluster
now when I want it.
Snap my fingers, and I'm in
app dev, and I get my database.
That's the model for Atlas,
and it's just exactly what
folks expect today.
But a lot of MongoDB
users don't actually
know MongoDB Atlas exists.
And they're kind of still
doing the traditional model
of, I download MongoDB,
the piece of software.
I install it on my
Google Cloud instance.
And then I have to manage that.
So one of the main reasons I'm
excited about this announcement
is, we'll get the awareness out.
All of our MongoDB community
of users out there,
for them to not know
that Atlas exists,
and that they can easily
live migrate into it
and suddenly get all
the benefits of being
in the modern world of true
as a service at the data tier,
it's a game changer for them.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, you said
something really interesting
there, just real quickly.
You said that you can migrate.
Is there easy migration paths?
Because I've done that, right?
Like I've spun up
three or four VMs.
I'm running
replication across them
or however I want to set it up.
And then if I want to
go from that to Atlas,
is that an easy journey?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Great question.
Yeah, so it's a
very easy journey.
So you'd spin up
an Atlas cluster.
You'd then click into
our live migration.
And basically from
there, you can
connect to a MongoDB
cluster that's
running in your own
self-managed environment of GCP,
or you can connect
to your environment
on the data center on prem.
And basically we're going
to pull the data over, do
the initial sync.
And then we're going to
apply all the changes that
have happened since
the start of it,
get you caught up in terms
of the operation time.
Once you're caught up,
you can literally just
bounce your app servers pointing
at the new connection string.
And you're over.
MARK MANDEL: Does that mean then
you can do hybrid cloud, too?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: So MongoDB is
very much built for that world.
You can run it in any context.
I wouldn't say that
an Atlas cluster can
sort of span both Google
Cloud, for example, and on prem
exactly.
But it's more like you can
have clusters in both contexts
and use MongoDB in same
way in both places.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Consistently.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: It's the
same API for the developer
essentially, no matter
where you're running it.
JON FOUST: Gotcha.
So I happened to stop
by the MongoDB booth,
and I got to talk with the very,
very friendly folks over there.
And one of the things that
came out of our conversation
was the mention of global VPCs.
So I was wondering if you could
tell our listeners a little bit
more, although I found
out about it at the booth.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: To
be completely honest,
we love Google Cloud Platform.
We're big fans of it.
We've been close partners for
really the last three years
when Atlas launched
three years ago.
And this announcement
that came out
this week about our
much deeper partnership
is just a continuation of that.
And one of the
reasons we've always
loved Google Cloud is the
nature of the global VPC, which
frankly, the other cloud
platforms just don't have.
MARK MANDEL: Can you
explain what that
is for people who don't know?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Basically,
it means that you can,
inside of a virtual
private cloud,
inside of a virtual network,
as a Google Cloud user,
you can easily build
your networking
across any set of
regions around the world.
You don't have to
set up, frankly,
a VPC per region and figure
out how to connect them
all to each other, which is like
an end to end many challenge.
Instead, it's just one big
network environment globally.
And the reason why we find that
really compelling and symbiotic
with MongoDB Atlas is that we
specialize in doing something
called global clusters.
A global cluster is a
cluster that essentially
has different zones
around the world
that it can take writes
inside of the same cluster.
So I might have my US
portion of my global cluster,
my European portion, my
Southeast Asia portion.
And customers in the US,
for example, and Canada,
and nearby, their data will
automatically read and write
to the US portion
of the cluster.
The European data will read and
write to the Frankfurt portion,
let's say.
And the same Southeast
Asia customers
will read and
write to Singapore.
So the data doesn't have
to leave the region.
And it gives you
in-region latencies.
Now that's super powerful,
and it's something
that we have in Atlas.
It's easy to configure that.
And actually,
literally the way you
use it is you define in your
document, in your schema,
you put a little
location field that
describes the country
of where the client is.
And that's where the
document goes in the cluster.
Simple as that.
That's fine and good.
But the question is, can our
customer actually use this?
Can they connect to it easily
and build their app tier
on top of that database?
On Google, it's so easy
because all they have to have
is one global VPC on
their app tier as well.
And they can set up their app
instances all over the world
and have them connect to that
Atlas cluster, which is simply
one VPC peering connection
into GCP, and we're good to go.
MARK MANDEL: That's amazing.
That global cluster, is that
specific to Atlas, or is that--
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yes.
So you could do that
yourself with MongoDB.
I mean, this is--
ultimately we're
using capabilities
that the core
database engine has.
But it's just the epitome of--
MARK MANDEL: It's just easy.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yeah,
if you do it yourself,
there's so much setup.
And it's just all
that stuff that nobody
wants to be doing anymore.
Because it's far
removed from what
matters to their
business, their customers.
But being able to build
in-region latency experiences
for global audience, we see
that as a very compelling thing
for more and more customers,
who, for a long time,
have gotten away with providing
excellent experience for US
customers and maybe not--
OK, for Europe and then
sort of, rest of the world,
we'll figure it out later.
Increasingly, it's
like, no, these
are huge economies growing fast.
We can't afford to
de-prioritize them.
Let's give them a
great experience.
We've got amazing adoption on
Atlas in countries like India,
I think.
Some of the largest fantasy
cricket leagues in the world,
for example, running on Atlas.
And it's just a real
testament to how
folks can come in on their
own, sign up, get going,
and reach any level
of scale so quickly.
MARK MANDEL: No,
that's super cool.
We've sort of alluded
to it a couple of times.
But we were talking about
that deeper partnership
with Google Cloud.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that, especially
for people who
weren't here at Next
or didn't see the live streams?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yeah,
so what was announced
by Thomas Kurian in the keynote
on Tuesday morning of this week
was Google recognizes
the strategic importance
of openness and of
harnessing the open source
community, of which MongoDB
is a key part at this point.
And so, as part of that,
Google has worked very closely
with us.
And we're going to continue
working very closely
to build out a first class
experience for MongoDB Atlas
native to the Google
Cloud console.
So, this is the
kind of thing where
it's ongoing work
to keep making it
a better and better experience.
Initially, it will be more
of a marketplace integration,
but eventually, it's going
to be the kind of thing
where inside of
Google Cloud console,
you can essentially describe
the Atlas cluster you want,
and you deploy it.
So it's all about making
it easier than ever.
It's all about aligning our
go-to-market operations,
so that our customers don't
have to sort of feel like,
who should I be talking to?
All the incentives are
lined up appropriately.
And I think it's just a
testament that Google realizes
it should open up
to the community
and that that's going to
be a win for its customers.
Kubernetes has been a
game changer for Google
because it has enabled
Google to level the playing
field between the
cloud providers,
make it easier to move around.
And our whole
philosophy with MongoDB
is that it should be super easy
to run your database anywhere
consistently as well.
So it's a lot of synergies
with the whole strategy
Google's got.
And we think it'll just make it
easier for everyone to migrate
into Google Cloud on Atlas.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it sounds amazing.
I guess, that means then
where it doesn't matter
whether a customer comes
to you, and they're
like, we want to run
this with Google Cloud.
Or they come to us,
and they're like,
we're looking for
a MongoDB solution.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: People end up
pretty much in the same place.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: It's a
win-win for both parties.
JON FOUST: Mark, I
don't know if you
happened to stop by the
MongoDB booth, but--
MARK MANDEL: I have
not had the chance, no.
JON FOUST: --I actually
got to see Atlas in action.
And one of the things that
really struck me as really
amazing was your analytics
and your metrics,
and monitoring your
clusters anywhere.
So could you speak
a little bit more
about that for our listeners who
will not be able to see that,
depending whether or not
they use the instance or not?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yes,
so I'll tell you.
Everyone on the
line, it's really
as simple as Google
MongoDB Atlas, sign up.
You can do a free forever,
free tier sandbox anytime.
You can deploy your cluster
and be up and running
in a couple minutes' time.
It's super easy.
We've got all kinds of
courseware and tutorials
to learn how to build an app
on it if you're interested.
We've got all the
bells and whistles
you need for a
production database,
ranging from real
time monitoring,
to historic metrics, to
index suggestions based
on slow queries.
We've got a Data Explorer,
so you can go in there
and really look at your
schemas, update your documents,
do anything you
need, run queries.
But absolutely,
MongoDB-- our sweet spot
has always been
operational database, OLTP,
the back end of
online applications,
engagement applications,
strategic applications where
customers are interfacing.
But increasingly, folks
have needs, of course,
to be able to report on
and understand what's
going on in those environments.
And so we've got the
ability to spin up-- again,
going back to our
distributed system--
you can spin up an
analytics replica
called the analytics node.
And you can actually, with
true workload isolation,
do deep aggregations, leveraging
all those same indexes,
and do any kinds
of reporting you
want on top of your
online cluster,
and truly have it isolated,
that same connection string--
super easy to set up.
And that allows you to
not necessarily need
to do those burdensome ETL
jobs to your traditional--
wherever you're going with it.
But also we've got something
called MongoDB Charts, which
basically gives you native
business intelligence
visualization--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: --on top
of the MongoDB data model.
None of the other popular
BI solutions out there
really excel at the
JSON data model.
They always kind of
have you force that
into the tables idea, and
you lose the fidelity.
Whereas what we've built
with MongoDB Charts is,
we don't want to give
up that fidelity.
And instead, you can
unwind arrays and deal
with subdocuments in a
totally MongoDB native manner
and build all those
beautiful visualizations.
MARK MANDEL: Do
you have some sort
of DSL for writing those queries
to pull stuff into charts?
Like, how do I build
charts on that?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yeah, so
if you deploy MongoDB Atlas,
you just click into
Charts on the left side.
And it's just a native
part of the Cloud platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
but if I'm like, oh,
I want a pie chart
with this data,
is there a particular
tool that I use or--
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
It's literally--
we've got a beautiful
GUI right there for it.
MARK MANDEL: OK, you'd be
like, oh, yeah, I just point
and click and do stuff.
Nice.
Very nice.
JON FOUST: Also, what
seemed very interesting
was the ability to
shard your clusters.
The demo for that
was pretty amazing,
especially when you had to deal
with fallovers and everything
like that.
So can you speak a
little bit about that?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yeah, sure.
So let's talk a little
bit more specifically
about how the distributed
system works in MongoDB.
There's kind of a couple
layers to talk about.
Before we talk sharding, which
is more about scalability,
let's talk about
replication, which
is about high availability.
So in MongoDB, for
example, every cluster's
automatically minimum three node
replica set on the back end.
That's simply three
replicas spread
across availability zones
in your target Google Cloud
region.
Or you can go across
multiple Google Cloud regions
if you want to
withstand full region
outages, that kind of thing.
Now, the way that replication
works is essentially
between those three,
they elect a leader--
a primary we call
it-- where writes go,
and the other two follow that.
If that one ever goes
down, then the other two,
among themselves, will
elect a new primary.
So this gives you
that high availability
that you need, with
like a two second auto
failover in the
event that there's
an outage of that primary.
And this is a key
building block that
allows us to also do
the vertical scalability
seamlessly.
In other words, if you want
to double your throughput
because Black
Friday's coming up,
or your game is super
popular, or whatever
your reason for
scaling up, that's
a couple of clicks in the
Atlas UI or an API call.
And what we'll do is actually
scale you up in such a way
that we'll leverage
that distributed system.
We're going to do
secondary, then a secondary,
then a primary, causing one
of those quick two-second
elections, we call them--
all meaning that,
essentially, you
have no-downtime way of
scaling up or down at any time.
So that's vertical
scalability, which
is really good for quick
reactions to demands.
MARK MANDEL: And when you
say vertical scalability,
that's like increasing
CPU and memory?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Yes, CPU, and
memory, and storage, et cetera.
So that's really good
for-- just basically,
I would describe as I
need to quickly scale,
especially if I might want
to scale back down later.
Now, there's another
kind of scaling,
which is what sharding is all
about-- horizontal scale out.
It's not so much about
quick reactive scaling.
It's more for long
term linear scale out.
So let's say I've got a
million new users coming
on the platform
every three months.
Maybe I need a new shard
to be added every three
months as a result. We can
simply do that in Atlas.
You set up your cluster
every three months.
You add a new shard.
And then basically, you're
just distributing your cluster
horizontally.
What's going to happen on
the back end is subsets
of the documents that are in
collections, which is kind
of like MongoDB's name for what
you traditionally might have
called the table, those
documents in those collections
will be spread across
the available shards.
And there's various
strategies for how
one selects their shard key,
depending on what you want
to optimize for, et cetera.
But essentially, this
means that you can go up
to any level of scale.
And that's why, for those of you
who may have kids on the line
or for those of you who
are yourselves addicts--
if you're playing "Fortnite"
all night, the level of scale
that powers the back end of
"Fortnite," that's MongoDB.
And the reason that's possible
is, again, the sharding,
the scale out capability.
You just can't do that level
of scale without sharding.
But for a lot of
applications, start simple--
a single replica set.
Vertically scale, and
then you can start scaling
out when you need to.
MARK MANDEL: An
interesting maybe question
on the sharding aspect as well--
I assume there are controls in
there for redundancy of data,
things like that, basically.
So you have just like one copy
of the data on one machine,
right?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: So that's
what the replication is.
In other words, yes.
I kind of jumped over that.
Every shard in Atlas just
automatically is a replica set.
That's just a building block
you don't have to worry about.
So you can have n shards.
But each of those
shards is always
going to be spread across
those AZs, Availability Zones,
in GCP, or across the multiple
regions if you prefer.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
So I'm curious what your
favorite feature of MongoDB is.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: That's
a great question.
So I mean, I've talked already
about just the fundamentals
of the JSON data model.
I think a favorite new
feature that I would
have to mention-- there's two.
One was in MongoDB 3.6,
which, again, capabilities
that folks who used
MongoDB years ago just
have no idea about, probably.
In 3.6, we introduced
change streams,
which lets you follow
what's happening,
changes in the database,
and do all kinds
of interesting
triggers based on that.
On top of MongoDB Atlas,
we've got a serverless layer
called MongoDB Stitch.
And you can do things like
triggers and functions
based on changes in
those change streams
and power all kinds of real
time applications that way.
But then the other
one that I have
to mention, just because
we've been waiting
on this for a long time--
in MongoDB 4.0, which
came out last year,
we introduced multi-document
ACID transactions in MongoDB,
which was--
MARK MANDEL: That's
a lot of words.
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
That's a game changer.
Yeah.
People think they
need transactions.
They oftentimes, in MongoDB--
because we have
atomic transaction
at the document level, they
oftentimes don't need them.
Because you're not spreading
your data across tables
anymore.
So everything changes.
You denormalize
into a document that
describes the business entity.
That's the MongoDB model.
But still, being able
to, when you need them,
have transactional
semantics to be
able to change multiple
documents together--
that was a key
building block that
went into hardening MongoDB.
It came out last year.
And now that's a huge
step forward for us.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So what's been also the most
interesting, or maybe weird,
thing that you've seen people
do with MongoDB, that you
can talk about publicly?
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
Yeah, I mean, I have
to search my mind on that one,
only because there's so much.
It's absolutely incredible to
have the scale of customers
that we've got.
Like, Atlas alone, we've got
about 10,000 customers, 400%
year over year growth.
But I kid you not, we have
300,000 users of our free tier.
Look at the MongoDB
community at wild,
it's hundreds of
thousands of MongoDB users
doing all kinds of stuff.
So it's more like
every day, I'm exposed
to millions of different
use cases for MongoDB.
And it's everything under
the sun, ranging from,
like I said before, powering
your most popular game
in the world, "Fortnite,"
to fantasy cricket leagues
in India, to a tier one
banking application that
powers your mobile
device, that's
running on your mobile device.
Some of the more interesting
use cases range from--
basically, think about the
apps that you know and love
the most.
Think about like dating apps.
Think about things
that are really
about engaging your
real life and making
your real life more fun and
interactive with other people.
I think some of
those are our work.
It's really interesting
some of the IoT applications
where folks have devices
out in the real world that
do all kinds of interesting
things and bring it all home.
Those are also
quite interesting.
JON FOUST: So you
mentioned community.
I was wondering,
what kind of support
does MongoDB give
for their community?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sure.
I mean, MongoDB has this,
just, enormous community.
We've got these community
created MongoDB user
groups, which happen, really,
in cities all over the world.
I invite everyone to check out
their local MongoDB user group.
I'm sure you can
find it on Meetup.
And go in there and just
connect with local folks.
We've got something called
MongoDB University, which
has over 1 million--
literally over 1
million registrants,
if you can believe
it, which is going
to provide on demand
video style coursework
for folks to learn
about MongoDB,
whether they're Python
developers, Node developers,
Java, or coming from
a DBA background--
all kinds of courses there.
There are incredible
tutorials, documentation.
We focus a ton on
all of that stuff.
We recognize that we're in
a long term secular shift,
a multi-decade secular
shift away from a world
where we think in
terms of tables,
to a world in which we think in
terms of JSON style documents,
and that we need
to continue to help
everyone evolve how they think.
And it doesn't happen overnight.
So we really focus
on so much of that.
We do a MongoDB roadshow,
conference style,
called MongoDB.local, which run
in cities all over the world.
There's one of those
happening every few weeks.
And then we have our big annual
conference, MongoDB World
in June in New York City.
Let's talk a little bit
about that secular shift
that's happening.
Because I think it's
controversial to kind of say,
we all came up on
table-based databases.
And we're going to
start seeing it shift,
I think, across the board
towards JSON rich structured
data-style databases.
It's controversial
because we're all hard
wired to expect
table-based databases.
Now, I'm going to argue that
the reason table-based databases
were introduced and
why they have become
ubiquitous is that if
you look at their origin
back in the 1970s, at that
time, the key problem table
databases was solving was
that storage was the key cost
bottleneck in computing.
You could throw as many people
at a problem as you wanted,
but you needed to
optimize for storage.
So it was important to
normalize everything
as much as possible to
just simply reduce storage
footprint.
Flash forward to 2019.
I always ask people this.
What do you think
the primary cost--
or just, what is the
primary bottleneck of today?
MARK MANDEL: Well, I don't
want to answer wrong.
I'd feel bad.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
Me, too.
Let's see.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: People have
all kinds of different answers,
but I would argue the
key bottleneck today
is our minds, particularly
developers' minds.
So if a developer
can feel superpowers
by using a data model that has
no impedance mismatch, database
that has no mismatch
with the data model
they already use
natively in their code,
they can do a heck
of a lot more faster.
And when storage is, frankly,
commoditized very cheap,
everything has switched.
So it's not that this
change happens overnight.
But there's just
so much inertia.
I mean, databases are not
things that change fast.
It's a huge cost to refactor.
And there's no way all these
table-based databases are just
going to become MongoDB.
I mean, that's not going
to happen overnight.
We're realists.
We recognize that maintenance
mode, status quo applications,
they're not going to change.
Even if they move to
the cloud, they're
not to be materially changed.
What's happening is folks are
looking at their applications,
and they're moving
to modern databases,
like MongoDB, for
applications that
are on the cutting edge of what
matters to those businesses.
Whether they're upstarts
trying to disrupt
or they're established companies
that have a strategic business
initiative that they know they
need to thrive on, or else,
they will be disrupted.
Those are the apps
where they need
to benefit from the
modern tools of agility
that developers can
wield, like MongoDB.
So it's sort of this--
we're going to see it
adopted more and more.
But the cool thing
is, it's being adopted
in the most exciting
applications, not in those
status quo ones.
So to answer your
question around someone
who's thinking about
making the shift
from table-based
databases to MongoDB,
my suggestion is it sounds
scary, but all you need to do
is look at your code.
So if you're a Java developer,
or Python developer,
or whatever it is,
look at your code.
Look at your objects.
Imagine if you didn't have to
have an object relational map,
and you could simply
take that object,
write it directly
into the database,
index on any field
in that database,
so you can query
however you want later.
When you read it back
from the database,
it's simply your
object again, using
MongoDB's built-in drivers for
all the programming languages.
It's really as simple as that.
It's all of a sudden
it's not that scary.
It's like, there's
actually not much there.
You're just going
directly to the database,
instead of going through that
mapping layer that introduces
this traditional pain.
Now folks are
scared of this, too.
Because there's so
much that has gone
into integrity and schemas.
And people really,
for good reason,
have built mature
applications over time
with a lot of controls in there.
And they can get scared
of adopting MongoDB.
It's going to be a
wild west of schemas.
And that's where,
I would say, we
have something called JSON
Schema, so you can control
your schemas in
MongoDB if you want to,
but with the full
richness, flexibility,
and expressiveness of JSON.
Again, it's just
all the benefits
of what our modern
tool chain looks like.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
I'm not going to lie.
Your speech on
bottlenecks and databases
makes me believe that pretty
soon, there will be something
called Davidson's Law.
MARK MANDEL: So what can
people expect from MongoDB
in the near future?
Are there any cool and updated
new features coming soon?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: There are
always cool and new features
coming soon with MongoDB.
Generally, I don't like to share
what's coming in this forum
because we like--
MARK MANDEL: So,
ongoing investment.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: I'll be honest.
We're a public company now.
We've got these incredible
public numbers that
are everyone in the world sees.
And as a result, there's
things I can't share.
But I can tell you that you
should always stay tuned,
particularly--
traditionally, we've
made our biggest announcements
at MongoDB World, which
is happening this
June in New York City.
JON FOUST: And is there any
way we can follow online--
say, a newsletter or
something we can sign up
for to find any more news?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Absolutely.
You can follow us on #MongoDB,
of course, on Twitter.
You can really sign up
on any of our websites.
But my main suggestion
for you is just
sign up for MongoDB
Atlas today, particularly
if you're a developer
out there, and you just
want to give it a go.
Five minutes to get started.
Have a "hello, world" experience
with MongoDB in the cloud,
free forever, free tier on GCP.
We have free regions all over
the world for you to try,
all the tutorials you
need to get started.
And have that aha
moment with MongoDB,
so you get what's going on.
And I think you'll
immediately see
how you can use it to solve
problems that matter to you.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us here at Next
in the Podcast House.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Thanks
so much for having me.
Great to meet you guys.
JON FOUST: Nice
to meet you, too.
So thank you to Andrew
Davidson from MongoDB.
It was a great and very
interesting chat, a lot of fun.
And moving on, we're going to go
into our question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How can I access Google Cloud
Shell from any terminal?
Mark?
MARK MANDEL: That is a
very good question, Jon.
So for those people who aren't
familiar with Google Cloud
Shell, this is a really
cool little thing
that if you go into the
Google Cloud console,
there's a little icon that
looks like a terminal.
Click that, and
inside your browser,
it will pop up a terminal
that has basically all
the standard tooling that
you need for doing just
about anything, so G
Cloud, Git, Go, Python, et
cetera, et cetera.
It's super handy.
It persists.
If your home
directory ever resets
and if you come back
to it after a while,
it will bring all the stuff
back again for a period of time.
Really, really handy stuff.
But you might find
there are scenarios
where you're like,
wow, I really wish
I could access my Cloud
Shell from the terminal just
on my local machine.
There's a bunch of different
tools that are available now.
They're in alpha, but you
will have links to them
in the show notes.
If you run G Cloud
alpha Cloud Shell SSH,
it will SSH into your
Cloud Shell terminal
and make it available locally,
basically through SSH,
which is super, super nice.
You can also use the G Cloud
alpha Cloud Shell commands
to SSP files up
and down, so if you
want to bring local
files to the machine
or bring them down as well.
But the thing that gets
me actually really excited
is that the G Cloud alpha Cloud
Shell command has a Get Mount
command.
So if you're running
Linux or Mac OS, basically
anything that can
support SSHFS, it'll
give you the command to mount
your Cloud Shell locally,
using SSHFS.
I think this is super cool.
Because maybe if you're
running on a machine--
maybe it doesn't
have as much power
or maybe as much network
bandwidth as you would have
running on GCP itself in the
Cloud Shell environment--
what you could do is mount
your directory locally.
Use your local tools
to edit those files.
And then run your
commands to, say, dock
or build something,
or pull down things
off the internet that
may be really large.
Do that in the Cloud
Shell environment
and then have access
to that, but still
have your local tooling as well.
I think that's super cool.
I'm very excited about it,
so I want to give it a shot.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it
sounds pretty cool.
And I can tell from the
excitement in your voice
that you're about to start
playing with it right
after this.
MARK MANDEL: Probably.
Awesome.
All right, well, Jon,
before we wrap up today,
where are you going?
Are you doing anything
fun in the near future?
JON FOUST: Well, I will be
attending my first Google
I/O next week.
So that's going to
be pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: It is going
to be pretty awesome.
And I will see you there.
I will be there as
well, giving a talk.
And I think we're both staffing
office hours and probably
some demo stuff, too.
JON FOUST: Yeah, so if you're
around, be sure to come stop by
and say, hey, we
heard your voice.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, we'll
probably be able to find us over
in the games area.
JON FOUST: Right.
[VIDEO GAMES SOUNDS]
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, Jon, thank you
so much for joining me
this week on the podcast.
JON FOUST: Thank you.
You know it's always a pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
JON FOUST: Yep, see you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]